this is a production of Cornell
University so yeah so I am Terry Bates I
am the director of the Cornell Lake Erie
research and extension lab in western
New York so we are about as far in the
western empire of Cornell as you can get
still be in New York and I do have a map
that I'll show you where we're from so
today I'm going to talk about what we
call the efficient vineyard project that
building there that is the Cornell like
Harry reaches research an extension lab
Cornell has actually been in western New
York working with the AG industries
especially the fruit production and
especially great production in western
New York for about a hundred and ten
years now there's been several different
labs in that western New York area the
most recent one was in Fredonia New York
we were there from about the mid 50's
until 2009 when we built the new
building somebody asked how did you get
the money do that and that was from both
the industry and primarily from senator
young so she was in our district and
head of the Senate AG committee and it
was a longtime desire for the industry
to have new lab facility dedicated for
research and Penn State as well there's
a Lake Erie regional great program the
Extension Program is a to state to
University cooperative effort which is
one of the only ones that's out there
and some of the people that are in this
photo so I like to acknowledge the
people that I work with at Clairol so I
will say Clairol Cornell Lake Erie
research and accession lab it's clear
off not the hair care product and so
there's a mix of people here so some of
them work for the Lake Erie regional
great program extension team headed by
Tim waggle who's IPM great New York
State grape IPM specialist
there's also Cornell Agrotech employees
there that help us run the farm and then
there are other scientists that are
actually employed through the USDA
funded scri project which we now call
the efficient than your project
okay so what is the efficient vineyard
project all about I'm gonna read this
sentence and I'm going to show you a
couple of slides and read the sentence
again and hopefully it'll make more
sense to you so so generally today I'll
be talking about precision AG precision
AG technologies that we use in the grape
industry so in a broad sense talking
about precision AG but in a very
specific sense trying to answer some of
the questions for our juice grape
industry in western New York so the goal
the projects to develop multiple sensing
and automation solutions for measuring
vineyard soil canopy and crop and I'll
talk about that and reconstitute
reconstitute those for high resolution
spatial crop load management now I'll
try to explain very specifically what
we're trying to get at in terms of crop
load and how that impacts our grape
industry
okay so again I'm from western New York
here's Buffalo here's Erie Pennsylvania
and this strip of purple that you see
are all the grape vineyards that are in
western New York so majority of the
grapes that are grown in New York are in
that Delft so you talk a lot about the
Finger Lakes since you're so close to
this region Long Island Lake Champlain
region different grape growing areas in
western New York but in in western New
York sorry in western New York we have
this lake plane right up against Lake
Erie so we're influenced by the lake
effect that we get from from Lake Erie
it moderates our temperature in the
region and that's why we can grow tender
fruit production in grapes being one of
them as that expand it out to all of the
Great Lakes so we have a primary
influence of Lake Erie on our grape
growing region but really and this is a
something that Stan Howell for Michigan
State used to tell me is that we have a
broader influence of all the Great Lakes
so as those cold air masses come down
from Canada it crosses all that water
that air gets conditioned and that's how
why we can grow tender fruit so it
doesn't get that cold in the winter
we have about a hundred and eighty
frost-free days in the region and then
there was that increase in elevation we
call that the Allegheny plateau the
escarpment you know the guys on the
Weather Channel's call it the the
Chautauqua ridge of Chautauqua County
this is Chautauqua County the Chautauqua
ridge that rise in elevation so when you
talk about lake effect snow we get all
the lake effect snow I mean it's not
uncommon for our region down on the lake
plane to get over a hundred inches of
snow a year if you go up that hill they
get about 200 inches of snow so again
just shows you that link influence that
we have in the area
okay the Concorde industry so one of the
reasons I actually even have a position
at Cornell is for the concord juice
grape industry in western new york so
you hear about Welch's or you go to
Wegmans and you buy Wegmans concord
grape jelly right it's coming from us so
in New York State and I do cheat here a
little bit because this piece of the pie
does include the concord vineyards that
are in Pennsylvania as well because it
goes down closer to Erie Pennsylvania so
a majority of the grapes grown in New
York are concord so you talk about all
the wineries that are in the Finger
Lakes and Long Island Hudson Valley they
actually make up a small percentage of
the total production of grapes so and
they're different markets to concord we
do on an international market right
Welch's is trying to out-compete with
orange juice and apple juice and there's
that economic impact there where most of
the wineries are very successfully
selling all their product out the front
door
so Concorde is very big but it has very
low profit margins so if you look at the
price paid for Concorde compared to
other wine grape region
wine grape varieties in the state we're
bottom dollar right about $200 a ton
where Riesling might be getting a
thousand dollars or more so so our
growers have low profit margins and we
have become increasingly mechanized and
here's my specific problem we're gonna
try to answer with general precision
agriculture you have conquered growers
they grow a lot of grapes can't just say
Oh conquer is not making any money we're
gonna start growing trim a net right if
one Concord grower with 200 acres plants
and all the tram Annette we've just
flooded the trevenant market for the
rest of the country so we're kind of
stuck with Concord as an industry and
we're trying we're getting rock bottom
dollars so for them to make a profit
they have to become more efficient we're
getting more mechanized so the the
concept that they have adopted in our
industry is that we leave more fruiting
buds and the vines could handle right I
want to set a very high crop potential
the way I want to be is to have high
crops I try to set that high crop
potential by leaving more fruiting buds
than I need and then I get past frost so
all those shoots come out those shoots
have clusters on them if we get frost
that reduces the crop size so it's risk
management strategy against mother
nature leave more fruiting buds than I
need and if I get past the threat of
spring frost I can SS do I want all
those fruiting shoots out there or not I
can use mechanical chute thinning this
is so this is a mechanical fruit fruit
mechanical crooner for grapevines so I
would say over 50% of our vineyards now
at least do some kind of mechanical pre
pruning with a hand follow up again
leave more buds than we need then we can
assess how many fruiting shoots we have
we want to reduce those throughout the
vineyard shoot positioning is a canopy
management process we use and then also
we use a mechanical grape Harvester to
thin fruit in the middle of the season
to try to match the crop with the
growing season and then we also use that
and then mechanical harvester during
harvest time to pick the fruit and what
we're doing uniform management and
non-uniform system so we're using all
these machines uniformly across the
vineyard right I take my mechanical
pruner or my paint canticle shoot
thinner and I just set the Machine up to
do one thing and the grower drives up
and down and what we're doing with the
precision AG is use spatial data to talk
to these machines and make the machines
either speed up or slow down as it's
going through the vineyard to reach our
crop load
okay so what do I need by crop load it's
a model based on a hundred years of
research that was mostly labor intensive
so we talk about crop load as a revised
index Oh something very specific to us
crop mass the pruning mass ratio and
what do we mean by pruning mass so in
the winter so one of a very
labor-intensive but fairly accurate way
of measuring how much vegetation the
plant grew the year before and what it's
cropping potential is for the next year
is to measure that through pruning wait
because pruning wait is directly related
to leaf area so getting out a
horticultural background soil water and
nutrient availability and the ability of
that plant to pick up water nutrients
will impart vigor on the vine right so
how much light interception per unit
land area we're getting translates to
productivity and we actually measure
that as pruning weight why don't we
measure leaf area directly we should we
don't it's difficult to do it's easier
to do it through pruning weight crop
weight is also something that is crop
estimation and trying to get crop total
total crop weights gonna be at the end
of the year also pretty difficult we're
trying to answer that with sensors so
when I say in that sentence I want to
measure spatially soil pruning weight
and crop weight characteristics
spatially throughout the vineyard I'm
putting all of those things into my crop
load model and we have a crop load model
I'm not gonna talk like for three
sessions about this but let me summarize
by saying an over cropped vine is bad
and under crock vine is bad and a
balanced vine is good and fit of
cultures across the world talk about
buying balance or vineyard balance and
all that really is saying is I want to
match my crop size with the amount of
leaf area I have out there and with my
growing season and we really have this
down with Concord again I leave more
crop than I need at about 30 days after
bloom I'm assessing what my season is
and what my crop size is and I'm
adjusting that crop to match this crop
load ratio and we tend up again over
cropper vines we leave way too much
fruit and then we try to dial it back so
we're playing whoo we're playing up here
in the over crop situation and we try to
bring them into balance with our
machines
okay so to develop multiple sensing
automation solutions for soil canopy and
crop and then reconstitute those with
our machines to do very very
applications to hit our crop load
balance within a vineyard
okay so we have a viticulturist you know
three guys walk into a bar
a viticulturist robotics engineer and a
precision AG specialist and they all
start talking about different things
which they're really talking about the
same thing so so one of the things about
this large scri USDA funded project we
had is a multidisciplinary and trying to
get people in the same room talking the
same language and we come up with this
measure model manage or sense plan act
data information decisions right so each
one of these guys is talking about
something a little bit different but
really talking the same language we want
to measure soil canopy in crop we want
to model what our crop load is and then
we want to manage that through
mechanization so we break it the project
down into measure
so again soil canopy crop sensors and
validation of those sensors you're gonna
hear me say validation a lot by taking
NDVI sensor which we use to try to get
an assessment of canopy growth and light
interception that NDVI sensors just
giving me an electric signal right it's
giving me you know this colorful heat
map that just I don't know what 0.7 NDVI
really translate to viticultural II so
we go out and we do stratified manual
samples in the vineyard against our
sensor measurements to translate that
NDVI signal into a pruning wait map and
then now that means something to me as a
grower in terms of modeling so multi
data layer processing so there's really
I look at modeling in two ways one is
how do we make the most out of those
spatial data right there's a lot of
noise in the spatial data there's a lot
of natural variation from vine to vine
in the vineyard
we're trying to pull out what the
underlying growth pattern is that in
your toe there are ways to process that
spatial data to try to pull that
information out and then as I explained
we're trying to also model crop load so
how does soil canopy and crop work
together for crop load balance in the
vineyard and then manage and software
hardware you know we're trying to take
spatial data through a computer and
control the mechanism on a machine so
that takes some engineering and variable
rate applications so as we apply those
variable rates how is it impacting our
growth
to be in the vineyard okay for soil we
use what we call a dual eeehm it's a m38
guys are all soil scientists you guys
know what I'm talking about because I
don't really understand it that well it
uses electromagnetic induction to give
you this is a dual e/m it oscillates
back and forth to give us a shallow and
a deep reading right so we hook this
sensor on a sled drive it through the
vineyard and we get a map it measures
electrical conductivity and magnetic
susceptibility at two deaths and does
that really mean again this is a sensor
measurement it's an electric signal
anything that conducts electricity in
the soil is gonna you know change the
way that sensor is giving me data what
I'm really interested in is the
viticulturist is that it gives me a map
right it gives me a heat map of that
vineyard and now I can I can break that
vineyard up into zones and I can
stratify my soil samples against it
right our guys do soil sampling but they
do it randomly right I'm gonna go out to
block H and I'm gonna take two soil
samples there's no direction in where
they're taking that soil sample at at
the moment by using one of these maps
they can be more directed and then you
know if the blue area makes up 40% of
the vineyard and say the orange area
makes up 60% now they can start having a
weighted average by what their soil is
like in that vineyard and mostly we look
at shallow electrical conductivity
because that has it's usually the clay
the type of clay and the amount of clay
that's in that shallow profile that's
having the most influence on our concord
vineyards why is that
well from a horticultural standpoint
owner did concord tend to be a shallow
rooted so the world of viticulture you
can use a rootstock and rootstocks have
different root growth habits there are
some root stocks that go straight down
there are ones that spread concord on
rooted tends to spread so that makes a
lot of sense to me that the amount of
clay content an organic matter and soil
PH and the upper profile of the soil is
going to have an influence on our vine
growth and production but a map like
this starts directing me to take samples
and be able to validate what's going on
in the vineyard so and for the most part
you know you get a County soil map and
when you use the soil sensor you're
getting a little bit more detailed maps
to work off of
and in our region so I showed that map
Lake Erie and the escarpment everything
is in the lake plane and those actually
from the lake to the escarpment is a
series of ancient beech ridges so like
every 30 feet of soil type changes and
we can start picking that up with that
soil sensor and as impact on our
management
for a canopy we use NDVI so normalized
difference vegetation index and it's
really using red and near-infrared wave
bands on a sensor so you can get NDVI
from a drone you get it from airplane
you can get it from a satellite we use
pretty much when we started the project
we're like what's cheap and easy so we
can buy these NDVI sensors there used to
be one called a green seeker that was
part of an tech tech and technologies
now I think it's bought off by Trimble
we use crop circle this crop circle
sensor has three wave bands so it's
sending out white light hitting the
leaves the leaves are reflecting the
light back and we're sensing with
near-infrared red and red edge and we
can use those three wave bands to come
up with different plant indices what I'm
really looking for from my standpoint is
is there a leaf there or not I need the
next video how explain that so so NDVI
is just a way to measure israel are
their leaves there and what's the health
of the leaf we put it up against the
canopy because I want to know where the
vines are growing very strong and where
the vines are growing very weak how that
changes throughout
so this is the old green seeker
beautiful really slow here's the crop
circle sensors that we're using now say
the three wave bands are go through
there that's a Gallo vineyard that's a
table grape vineyard so this is a
national project where you working in
vineyards both here in New York in
California that's a merlot vineyard in
California okay here's a here's a
vineyard in Michigan so this gives you a
good idea where the canopy was very
sparse we're gonna get low NDVI values
and now it's here where it's very thick
we're gonna get higher NDVI values and
we get again we get maps like this where
it's showing me where their vines are
are pretty weak and where the vines are
pretty strong so in terms of Concord
outward horticulture again high wire
cord on the shoots come out and then
they droop down which it might be
different than a lot of the vineyards
you'll see around here with like
Riesling would be a low wire cordon with
upward growth habit and things are put
up and do catch wires so you have a
vertical chute position system so we
work on both but here in Concord if
early in the season this makes a lot of
sense we use one sensor we used to use
an array of sensors that didn't really
help us out we use one sensor here and
as that vine grows throughout the season
we actually drop the sensor so I know if
one vine is growing very very strong
right this is the sensor will saturate
if I still have week vines Anila season
I'm gonna mean getting lower signatures
so again really we're just seeing are
there leaves there or not and it has a
little bit to do with the health of leaf
but we don't really address that too
much at this point although that's on
the horizon
okay validate validate validate so again
we take a heat map we take man so we'll
stratify samples based on that map this
is a guy collecting pruning weights and
the so again we either through machine
or by hand you prune a vineyard you
actually pick up the sticks and you
weigh them it's a very labor-intensive
process nobody wants to do it in the
middle of February one of the reasons I
started this project as I said I never
wanted to printing weights ever again
and now I take more pruning weights than
ever before so we look for those
relationships what is a relationship
between vine sizes the pruning weight
and our NDVI signature and the vineyard
so I can translate this color map that's
an NDVI map into an actual pruning
weight map and I use that my pruning
where my crop load formula and we do the
same thing with growers right so we have
we actually have a a loner sensor
programmer now so as growers are out
spraying their vineyards or mowing their
vineyards or applying fertilizer they
can they can put one of these sensors on
their tractor collect data for us they
come back to us we process the data
we'll give them the map will define
where the transects are that they can
take their validation measurements and
then so every vineyard at their own like
internal standard for what their NDVI to
pruning weight relationship is so we're
turning a pretty picture this pretty
picture of NDVI actual into a pruning
wait map and when you talk to growers
you know one-pound by and 2 pi by 3
pound by means something to them more
than an NDVI value crowd
estimation so the industry is very hot
on this topic of prop estimation I want
to know midseason either destructively
or non destructively what my harvest
weight is gonna be they want to know
within 5% and if you're dealing with a
five acre vineyard yeah you probably do
that when you're dealing with 30,000
acres it's a really difficult question
ask because there's so much variation
out there soil management buying growth
are all impacting me traditionally a
viticulturist throughout the season will
measure what we call yield components
they'll do it manually sampling
typically random can we make that better
by stratifying our samples we think so
but they will measure shoot counts
because all these shoots have clusters
on them so number of shoots will relate
to what your total crop way it's gonna
be
clusters per shoot or cluster count bury
count so a Concorde flower cluster may
have a hundred florets on them and about
thirty of those will set well some years
it's 25% some years that's 35% right so
it'll change so knowing what the berry
count per cluster is and then berry size
so these yield components shoots per
vine clusters for shoot berries per
cluster and berry size all impact what
our final process timet is going to be
we are working with engineers at
Carnegie Mellon who have developed this
image analysis system so they take this
red machine it's a stereo image called
the shiny red bike it goes through the
vineyard and it takes pictures of the
vine so at different times of the season
when it's you know early season shoots
or mid season cluster counts or berry
counts or berry sized it stitches those
images together and then they use
algorithms to count what's in those
images and so far it works very well at
counting what it can see it doesn't do a
very good job counting what it can't see
so if you're trying to count berries on
a cluster if those clusters are exposed
like in a vertical chute position system
where the leaves are pulled and the
clusters are hanging out there it's very
accurate accounting varies but then you
also have berries hiding other berries
so they deal with this occlusion factor
or visibility factor so they're trying
to measure
yield components identifying what
there's some other occlusion factors are
and then they try to try to make a crop
estimate based on that okay here's a
video of the thing in action
we will use it during the dormant season
thinking they're trying to developed
algorithms to count buds so dormant buds
and then shoots and they work in table
grapes looking at color development so
this thing goes down it flashes we use
stuff like leaf blowers to try to get
the leaves out of the way so we can take
pictures of the fruit this is a merlot
vineyard in California so again this is
this is what is taking a picture of this
is what it is going through its
algorithms to count the fruit that's
there and then it's developing a spatial
map of very counter process that
vineyard and then we validate that with
yield monitors I'll talk about that in a
second so a here's their CMU imaging a
very count in that vineyard and then the
harvest yield monitor is what this is
what we get off of the yield monitor and
we try to look at the relationship
between those two and see how close they
match yield monitors okay so it's all
coming together here so we're evaluating
two yield monitors on a harvester and
this really helps with you know we have
a crop estimation in the middle of
season and what is our final crop weight
at the end of the season so there's a
yield monitor one was developed in
Australia and then there's another one
that was developed by a company called
Oxbow it is sits right here the one from
Australia on the cross conveyor so you
ever seen a grape harvester work grape
harvester goes over one row it shakes
the vines the fruit falls off it goes
over this conveyor belt into a chase
tractor into bins and those bins get put
on a trailer and then they go to the
processing plant
so this yield monitor has a false way
frame and as the as the fruit goes over
the belt it's recording a weight and we
can map that everything's hooked up with
GPS we also have another one called an
oxbow type Oxbow is a company that makes
like pea harvesters and grape harvesters
and they have an impact plate one so so
many of you are probably familiar with
grain harvesters they use an impact
plate as grains coming off it's hitting
a plate and then they translate that
into a yield signal we're doing the same
thing with grapes
again validation so whether it's the
impact plate or the false way frame
we're relating the yield that's coming
off of the sensor to actual either
bucket weights or bin weights or actual
truck weights that go into the plant
we're relating those to what the yield
monitor says and we're getting nice
relationships so we can use that
something that's hot off the press so
this image was actually made earlier
this week during our harvest this year
is juice soluble solids mapping so grape
growers get paid for their grapes based
on yield and sugar content juice soluble
solids something we call Brix the we
measure refractive index of the juice
and we call it bricks and so they get
paid on yield and bricks right and
there's a minimum Brix level if you drop
below that minimum bricks your load gets
rejected or you go into a low solids
program and you get paid a lot less or
their grapes so growers are really
interested to know what their yield and
their sugar content is as they're
harvesting because if they go into a
field and the bricks are too low they
have to go to another field and pick the
fruit that's ripe or they do they do
something well just doesn't want to hear
about Kyle Field blending is they will
put unripe fruit in a bin and then
they'll go to a field that's ripe and
they'll cook more sweet stuff on top and
try to get that into the plant we're
trying to eliminate field blending so if
we can we if we can either measure juice
soluble solids on the fly or use our
crop load models to predict you know
this fields gonna write them last this
one's gonna ripen earlier lets you know
that directs the grower to be able to go
out and pick the fruit when they need to
so okay so there are inline
refractometers that you can purchase and
they use them in factories and you can
measure the Brix that's not that's not
like the development what is my crew has
been working on and we're gonna try to
protect the intellectual property is how
to get juice to the refractometer so
grapes are falling off of the belt and
you can it's very difficult to measure
the you know Brix of all that you're
getting non soluble solids in there as
well so skins leaves it so guys that
I've worked with a
have developed the processing unit that
bounced onto a harvester that actually
samples a portion of the fruit that's
falling off of the belt and it puts it
through a mechanism that sends juice to
the refractometer refractometer reads it
and actually the juice goes back on the
belt to be harvested and and these are
the first maps that are coming off of
that system so we're pretty happy with
that
okay I keep moving modeling so those
that's our measurement right we're
measure soil canopy crop you have these
different sensors you know do Liam NDVI
destructive and non-destructive yield
monitoring with the CMU imaging system
we also have a destructive system that
we use that we actually go out and clean
pick fruit in the middle of season try
asked me what scent so there's there's
different ways of doing that and now
we're we also measure you know yield and
Brix monitoring so all those sensors are
working together now we're talking about
modeling of the spatial data so again
when I first started doing this I did it
probably like most people who are
getting into this business is you know
we have you have 40,000 data points in
the field you project those through
ArcGIS or some other spatial program you
know and you try to do some data
smoothing and and you get a you get a
picture that's and it's and it can be
very useful but there is information in
that spatial data that is difficult to
get out and so we use both global very
old Graham modeling and local very okra
modeling to make these images and again
what a very Oh Graham tells us is how
much of the variation in the vineyard is
random right so I have big and small
vines over here but most of them are big
I have big and small vines over here but
most of them are small so there's a lot
of this randomness that's going on and a
global very own gram of a field will
tell me Oh 50% of your variation is this
random I use a word crap it's random
crap and it's just like making noise of
my data and then 50 percent of the
variation is spatially structured it's
based on oh my soil type is more clay
over here it's more gravel over here and
that is that that's what I want to
manage against so I want to be able to
capture that and that's what this kind
of modeling does for us
so as these the smoothing technique I
guess is the best way to say it it's
actually looking at every data point and
it's looking at the neighbors of data
points around each one to say as I get
farther and farther away
how are those points influencing this
point and it smoothes that data and it
does it in in in a way in which we can
extract the pattern out of the vineyard
and then we project so this smoothing
process is done on a common grid so
every and hour
we just happen to select a grid size
that is equal to our vine density so
it's basically every grid point equates
to a vine and I know now that I put
project everything onto a common grid I
can look at the soil map the canopy map
and the crop map and I can mine through
that data and say at this point in the
vineyard I'm standing here all right I
have this kind of soil it's imparting
this kind of vine growth and I should
probably be able to hang this kind of
crop here to get it ripe in a average
growing season and I'm using that now to
manage my vineyard
so then we look at all these data so
we're collecting all this data right so
one of the comments that the industry
growers will say ah I'm in California
and I pay someone to do a flyover of my
vineyard of NDVI and I have all these
maps sitting on my desk no idea what to
do right that's a big issue with the
industry is I have data I don't know
what to do with it so what we do again
since everything is projected down to a
common grid I can mine to that data I
can look for correlations between the
soil and the canopy and the canopy in
the crop and there are some images where
I'm like yeah it's garbage right like
the deep magnetic susceptibility is just
something streaky map and it doesn't
mean anything to me
where say a shallow EC a midseason NDVI
and my yield map all have some kind of
correlation that's going on I use so so
we talked about at some point in the
process of all this we need to have the
growers input right you need you need it
the grower has based on their economics
based on you know what they're growing
in and for what fruit market they have
their own idea what they want to do with
the vineyard so at some point they need
to come into the process and this is
where they would come in to say yep I
know there's a low spot in my vineyard
and I know that's affecting my
productivity solely I'll leave that
layer in and then we do we find the
layers that we want we do we call it
k-means clustering alysus so it's taking
the data from say these four layers and
is creating zones and it is trying to
mean separate those zones as much as
possible and reduce the variation within
those zones so you have discrete zones
within a vineyard that hopefully makes
sense viticultural e and you can also
click on the red and it'll tell you oh
you have this kind of soil this kind of
canopy in this kind of crop how do you
want to manage it same thing with the
red for the green in the blue zones okay
we measure with all our sensors we model
that data doing the spatial data
processing coming up with our management
classifications and now we have to
manage it so I'll give you best way to
try to describe this is through an
example so here's a grower is a concord
vineyard it has a small a medium and
high buying growth area right and we do
our crop estimate in middle of the
season and we know that the red zone has
about 8 tons per acre and but we know
those vines are really small you cannot
you cannot ripen 8 tons per acre on that
part of the vineyard then the Blue Zone
are big healthy vines have more water
more nutrients they can ripen a larger
crop and they're hanging almost 12 tons
per acre and we're like you know what
given the growing season you probably
can ripen on that much so I want to take
off more fruit here actually to try to
get the small vines and balanced and the
big ones take off a little bit I want to
leave more crop because it's able to
ripen their crop and we do that with a
harvester machine so so this harvester
middle of the season it is gonna it just
like it harvest where it shakes the
vines but it's gonna shake them more
gently and it'll take off say I want to
take off 2 tonnes breaker here it'll
take it off maybe I want to take off 1
ton per acre here it'll slow down the
beater speed and take off less fruit
so we have our spatial data goes into
our map the map talks to this computer
we use an AG leader system Trimble and
Raven you know Chevy Ford people have
their favorites we use AG leader just
because that's the system we work with
so it goes into the their software so we
actually tricked this system this is
really meant for liquid fertilizer
application so it's all about flow rates
so we actually have to tell in the dark
blue zone I want this flow rate and in
the light blue zone I want a different
flow rate and instead of going to the
liquid dispense of fertilizer we send
that signal to what we call a PWM valve
a pulse width modulation engineers are
out there you know I'm talking about
it's basically a hydraulic valve that
chirps the faster chirps the more
hydraulic fluid they go through and the
faster the machine works and vice versa
as it goes slower so the map talks to
the PWM valve and then the harvester
just goes so at crop estimation time we
want to take off all the fruit so we
drive very slow and we shake the vines
really hard and we harvest that fruit we
collect and weigh it we're using that to
do our crop estimate that's how I got to
the I have eight tons per acre here and
I have 12 tons per acre somewhere else
and then when I want to just shake off a
little bit into the different zones this
is so this isn't the throat of a
harvester and so now we're driving much
faster somewhere between five and six
miles per hour through vineyard but
shaking the vines very gently just to
get a portion of the fruit to fall off
and then we put that into our crop load
model remember so going way back to
natok fruit way to pruning weight ratio
we're using our spatial data validated
against those kind of measurements to
come up with a harvest yield map so our
crop weight our pruning weight map based
on NDVI we actually do the math between
those two to come up with our crop load
or revise index and in these strips here
are controls where we didn't do anything
you can pick those out so the red color
would be over cropped and by doing
variable rate thinning within that
vineyard if we made it more uniform so
pre thinning we had vines in the red
green and blue zones that were all over
cropped so here's my revised index I'm
trying to my where I wanna be balanced
vines are about 15 so we got stuff
that's way up in the 3035 so these are
way over crop but we need to bring the
Reds down more than the blues and that's
what we did so we after thinning after
variable rate thinning we've shifted
these population curves down so that's
what I'm really trying to do the
ultimate goal is I want to shift the
population of those vines where I want
them and I want to make them more narrow
right more uniform because that's gonna
have a lot of commercial benefit for our
grower that a they're balanced and B
they're they're not as variable so my
fruits gonna be more uniform coming into
the harvest okay just a couple benefits
that we've seen so far you know I knew I
had a problem I didn't know it was that
big so that's like the first thing we're
getting benefits out of just a single
data layer whether that soil or canopy
or crop it's giving growers an idea of
wow I had no idea that I had that much
variation my vineyard I didn't know I
was losing so much money in this one
section because my crop was too low or
my vines are too weak and I need to do
something about it improved crop
estimation so there's a question of crop
estimation on an individual farm versus
crop estimation for an industry I think
they're two totally different questions
I think we're addressing the first one
how do I get crop estimate in my
particular farm the goal is to be within
5% we're using spatial data to stratify
our mid-season crop estimation
samples and that's putting us somewhere
in the five to ten percent accuracy
range of looking in commercial vineyards
if we use random sampling we are off
anywhere from ten to twenty three
percent and probably somewhere around
twenty five to thirty percent is what
the industry would say that they're off
every year about thirty percent of what
they thought they were going to be at so
we think the stratified sampling is
going to give benefits to our crop
estimation to get with the five percent
range
preventing just one rejected low pays
for the technology so in this case we're
doing on-the-fly yield and Brix
monitoring again if if I have a grower
and I have a semi load of concord grapes
that's worth six thousand dollars and I
goes to the plant it gets rejected or it
goes into a low solids program I've just
lost a lot of money out of my operation
so if I'm picking and I can see what's
going on be able to visualize the fruit
ripeness in the field then I can prevent
that from happening and the technology
to pay for itself and this is the quote
I love the best making a decision and
made I saved my ass and in October so
this one this is actually just said to
me last week so one of the growers were
working with we were doing at the
variable rate shoot thinning work in his
vineyard
so again left way more buds and he
needed
we went out did early season NDVI
related at shoot count so then and he
had idea oh I want to leave about 120
shoots in this vineyard maybe less on
these vines more on this vise we did a
variable rate shoot thinning trial in
May so he got passed that thread of
spring frost could assess what his crops
gonna be you variable rate crop
adjustment at that time and he did it
there's one field where we did the
experiment in there was another field
where he didn't do the experiment in and
he could that fruit was just not getting
rifles we've had a lot of rain this fall
so the sugar went up and it's kind of
just kind of hung out there and he went
to pick that field couldn't get it right
went over to the field where we did the
variable rate shoot thinning it was able
to take down load so he said that you
know at least on that particular day the
technology safe
so who so thank you for listening yes
so Julie Tarara is she was a researcher
out of Washington State and then with
USDA did develop a strain gauge on for
the wire and so so the answer is yes and
she there's some published work on that
I don't have Justine you have anything
to add to it just so-so
so again like with a lot of our sensors
you have the strange gate strain gauge
on there and there's a lot of noise and
then you use a software that kind of
eliminate that noise and then throughout
a season you can feel how that you know
oh there's more tension on that wire and
less and you have to separate out how
much of that weight is canopy and how
much of it is cropped yes so that that's
all part of our kind of our crop load
decision so we've been doing destructive
crop estimation work for 20 years now so
the way we do it is is a grower will
actually take a rope that's 1% of an
acre so forty eight point six feet lay
that out in the vineyard and clean pick
that 1% and weigh the fruit and based on
the berry curve 30 roughly 30 days after
bloom is 50% of final weight so at 30
days after bloom they they pick four
tons per acre they know they're gonna
have eight tons per acre at harvest
based on weather conditions so
especially the timing of bloom we kind
have rules of thumb that we go by it's
like for every three days is equal to a
ton if I'm three days early I'm bloom
that's an extra ton I can if I'm a week
late on bloom that's two tons I probably
can't write them that I would normally
write then as far as long-term data sets
so we have phonology dates right same
set of vines that we've collect bud
break bloom ver Asian harvest dates on
and we do see a trend you know over the
last 50 years a trend towards earlier
bud break earlier bloom and that should
translate into more fruit that we can
ripen it Falls also seem to be getting
wetter so we've had a lot of rain just
in the last couple weeks and that'll
hurt us in terms of trying to ripen that
fruit as well so I don't know if I
answered your question okay yes and no
so yes we started to use lidar very
early in the project and it was more
towards canopy structure not much with
with berry weight and yes I agree with
you there are other sensors out there
that I think could help us Carnegie
Mellon is really focused on their image
sensor they can get answers yes but
we're not using
so yeah so if you go back to 1960
there'll be a curve on pruning wait and
yield and it does the same thing so as
the vine gets bigger within its defined
space as a vine gets bigger it produces
more leaf area and then then it if 100%
fills that canopy space and by making
the vine even bigger or more vegetative
all you're doing is packing it with more
leaves but you're those leaves aren't
productive because they're tucked up
into the shade so we see the same curve
we see that with our NDVI because it is
the sensor is pointing at the canopy on
the outside and you're getting you know
when the canopy is not filled it's
increasing by the time that canopy is
filled it it saturates that sensor so
that curve flattens off
I think that's translatable to other
vineyards then I still say the number
one problem in our industry is lack of
vine size right
we almost I would say almost all of our
vineyards are dealing with the 1 to 3
pound by not the 3 to 5 pound by if you
go to a winery that's on a very vigorous
root stock and Justine knows very well
by stuff does a lot of her work is on
decrease in figure so there are a lot of
wineries that are dealing in the three
to five pound vines and they're actually
trying to bring the vine size down
so I think the way to answer your
question is if you're below 100 percent
canopy Phil I think NDVI is very good I
think if you're above 100 percent canopy
Phil I don't think NDVI is very good and
you need other technology whatever that
is to measure canopy density would be
good one question about finding that is
so plants generally do numbers or even
after it begins to grow if the
conditions of the environment it's not
adequate fans do now
and yet it seems that in your dreams
they tend to be very liberal of for to
maintain and you're making the
adjustment finding constants and that
contrast a lot with my experience in
Maine where generally what we found is
that the germplasm the phenotypes that
are out there
dignity too conservative relative to
what borrowers would like and through
reading and trying to get the plants to
not afford to become barren lands under
stress conditions so can you make a
comment on what is it that's different
about grapes no it's not that different
we do measure the yield components and
as we increase bud number we will
increase yield but that there's a
diminishing return on that right as you
increase by number the yield goes up but
the you know
per shoot we'll go average clusters per
shoot will go down average berries per
cluster will go down average berry
weight will go down and we actually put
all that stuff into our into our crop
load model account for that but really
the bottom line for us is that we can
over crop of I like the the reduction in
yield components isn't as great as you
can make it so I can leave a hundred and
fifty buds on a Concord vine on a eight
foot spacing and it could potentially
produce 12 to 15 tons breaker which we
will never get ripe if I left it there
vine size will end up going down because
because of carbohydrate balance so about
midseason to the till final harvest so
we've done studies looking at starch
accumulation and perennial structures if
you are have the vine that is over crop
the starch starch is going into the wood
sugar is going into the fruit late in
the season and and that there's a
balance there too much crop you're gonna
get less starch into the wood so less
root growth less vine size less pruning
weight less productivity for the next
season so what we tend to see is you
over crop a vine cause you forced it by
leaving too many buds you drive vine
size down and your production goes down
over years actually when I started
working at Cornell there was a big issue
called Miller and Dodge and they we all
I think we finally came up that it was a
carbohydrate issue is so growers started
going to minimal pruning which was they
just skirted devine so you suddenly left
you may have a vine that you prune to
sixty buds for twenty years so you you
kind of kind of kept the crop load down
they were balanced so there were strong
vines and then all of a sudden you left
400 buds by just hardly pruning at all
and it was a system that came out of
Australia so all of a sudden you had 13
tons per acre 13 tonnes per acre and
then the next year came back with two
tons per acre and then bounced back up
to 15 tons per acre and the years that I
had two tons per acre all the clusters
were there but the fruit never developed
so it's it's similar it's just the way
we attack it now as we try to try to
bounce it leave a little bit more crop
that we need and adjust down as
necessary
that's very good questions regarding
thinning the roots
it's the are these range the very center
whether the damage of a problem if you
do it right no again we've been doing
this as for as long as I've been here it
was was a system that was started with
Bob pool before before I came on board
and yes you will talk to growers and
there have been horror stories so the
harvesters we used to use they have rods
in them and they used to have straight
rods and they used to hit the vines like
this and there's on a whip action at the
end and there was a lot of broken shoots
a lot of damaged berries and people said
thinning mechanical thinning is never
gonna work
and into this day I have old growers
like you're killing my vines never do
that again
but now the harvesters we can tighten up
where the bow rods are they're not
street rods anymore they're bow rod so
there's no whip action and now were
there in sync so so we actually grip the
vine and we just shake it a little and
again there's a variety issue thing here
Concord at the end of the season we'll
have three grand berries middle of
season winter thinning they're about
one-and-a-half cranberries most vanilla
especially like Riesling that's a tight
cluster variety at the end of the season
will be one point five gram so the
berries are much smaller so again kind
of cord loose clusters big berries
middle of season it actually works
fairly well for us that we have trouble
with tight cluster different varieties
there are other machines out there that
are trying to do it but yes we get a lot
of
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu